alright alright y'all this episode is
brought to you by Buffy you can check
out their latest product the breeze it
is a comforter made entirely of a
hundred percent eucalyptus fiber to
regulate the temperature and keep you
cool comfortable all night long for $20
off your Buffy comforter use the code
b-tch okay okay that's it both at the
cut your up here cuz I know you want to
take hot I know you want to keep talking
about but you know I want talk about
that comforter Oh we'll bring it back
well I wouldn't talk about that for now
welcome back to hey [ __ ] that well I
did was I was gonna steal Nikki's intro
because I don't have one plan but okay
welcome back to hey [ __ ] we are the
[ __ ] I was wasn't ready for the
execution there that's okay uh who we
got on today we've got me Geo
I should just left it at me me bows and
then me Gina and we have an amazing
special guest me okay that's right boys
and girls shouldn't mean if you're not
familiar with her if you've been living
under a rock our girl is one of the og
twitch star has been in the game for
like how many years now about six move
about yeah six yeah all those Instagram
folks clocking in I want to say three
point six million followers like [ __ ]
insane I was scrolling through Amazon
Prime the other day and there was a
pokey main show oh there was a pokey
main show what we're not playing
we're not worthy really gotta give the
girl some just really got to give you
some like props for I mean stayin in the
game for so long and being practically
scandal-free and being so essentially
stoic in your career because when you
have so much stuff being thrown at you
online on a regular basis it's so easy
to just fall under in the internet world
like ppl takeo they'll come after you
especially when they're as big as you
are
yeah you're this cute fragile very like
like flower s girl in a man not man a
boy dominated okay that's just something
I mean really
able to go toe-to-toe with these people
and keep the poise I think above all
pokeyman is definitely an idol for girls
for having some poise because like me
you know I'll go straight to Twitter -
Twitter strain their lawyer worried
right now because he just murdered some
people on Twitter yeah I mean while
pokies out here dishing out advice she
got a doctorate in advice you not
actually but I do like a little a little
segment on my stream doctor pokey yes so
mad props mad respect and we're so so so
excited to have her here oh we want to
pick your brain we want to like what
like wait can I just say this girl is
like my intros like not gonna be really
good yeah I guess just biography of you
did great
incredible I've been in the game for a
minute i watch I listen yeah I still
remember like I feel like I think it was
like two years ago I've been conned
we're in wait what you not remember that
all right cool car I'm in a car with you
here / - yeah and like pokey gets in the
car behind me and I'm like I've
literally been streaming on the same
platform with this girl for like four
years this is a four year working a
small shut up yeah yeah yeah and I was
like I see well stream so much yeah all
over the place man boy you know what how
crazy we meet here in the middle um but
you know we just wanted to hop right in
and maybe find some common ground
amongst all of us you know we're all on
social platforms guys if streamed I
don't know how into video games you are
man I don't know what I'm sorry I think
I've lost clearly I'm not dressed the
right way I'm not I don't I just want to
get educated right now so please educate
me you can get the gamer memo we wear
all black actually true over here you'll
walk out of the bathroom in this shirt I
was like geo I can see your nipples what
a [ __ ] treat if we can zoom in really
quick oh thank you no thank you
I like the necklace it's very true love
you oh thank you I want to learn about
gaming well I actually kind of want to
dive into a little common ality that I
feel like all of us have a little story
about but I definitely want to know what
coquí's packing in terms of very creepy
DM Oh what are we gonna find in your DM
request outbox yeah dude yeah I don't
know no I've been I've been streaming
for six years right so it's like there
are so many DM stories I've probably
forgotten but they just keep coming and
it's like there's a you know there's
like creepy one-off DMS and then there's
like people who get a bit more
stalkerish I know there's people that
show up to your house about it they're
gonna drop off there's gonna want to
listen to it anymore you're gonna give
them the tips in their pillow and belly
burger time but also like feel free to
share your stories oh we are yeah
that'll like trigger my mood yeah yeah
and this one guy did blah blah blah yeah
I know we will I'm sure there's a lot of
feet ones I oh yeah there's a lot of
feet ones yeah all right you guys heard
of a wiki feed yeah Mon yeah we're all
on there have 4.9 stars out of 5 someone
check mine update
I hate when I'm filming something and
like I pop it to animation and they're
like they're like yo yes they are is
incredible yeah I don't know who it is
but like literally I'll post it on my
snapchat and like five minutes later
it's on there it's wild I'm pretty sure
it's one guy with 9 monitor it's like
whatever probably shirring yeah and it's
like really huge monitor so he doesn't
miss a damn tone and there's one dude
that used to donate to my stream and he
called himself Google Doc guy and he had
a Google Doc of every picture I've ever
posted anywhere okay when I I'd be like
21 and it's like pictures me around like
600
how the [ __ ] about this [ __ ] wait
important question though this depends
on like this this really decides if he's
creepy or not does he donate a lot just
be like nice latest pic added it to the
doc and like it's like a dollar like one
alright
Oh like diligent I was a little
impressed to be honest celebrity gossip
cárdenas did it turn you on did it work
not really turn me on I was like an
interesting archive of my life on
internet you this is actually really
good because if someone would be like
pokey team I'm not one time Bobo ball
you're like hold on I don't have a photo
but let me just hit up my guy really
quick and I bet even have it know like
what is it fun entrepreneur you are you
put him a payroll yeah nevermind creepy
guy I love you you're hired
hired buddy I'm paying you $1 for per
photo
okay let's start really basic though
it's not really basic with you what what
is like a basic creepy DM that you get
um the thing is I don't have like super
open diems and I try to limit my
exposure to random comments um but also
I you just get creepy [ __ ] everywhere
whether it be in your twitch shot well
Twitter outbox DM which I guess I have
now and then your others in Instagram
it's anything from like you know send me
feet pics to send me finger picks to
speaker pics I've known that like
bellybutton pics like there's people
that are instant and everything someone
wrong with you because I don't I only
get underwear feet uh I think I getting
asked for my time was pretty like yeah
like can we chat can we face it's like
no a lot of people do it started
happening a lot more when I start
streaming people think I'm like their
personal therapist like I'll get four
paragraphs like what should I do with my
life I'm like bro ya know oh my god I
feel bad when I get those because like I
want to help but it's like I could spend
all day answering DMS you know what I
mean and sometimes okay here's here's
the thing that maybe you guys know bit
about but you probably don't when it
comes to twitch streaming you build a
completely different relationship with
your fans than you do on any other
social media no these people don't just
see a poster they're like oh cute like
these people like watch you for like 6
hours a day yeah do that day in and day
out like yeah you create a very
interesting I think it's called like an
intra personal relationship like they
know you so well and like they feel like
you're there for
and Blake you don't know them at all
yeah so that disconnect sometimes shows
through and like the messages you get
your interactions in person
I had a full-on relationship with a guy
without realizing it Oh same ID right
now how does that happen
gimme gimme gimme does it ever concern
you guys even talking about it because
some of these people have to give them a
little bit of attention that's like
that's enough that's missing now it may
it's no longer a one-sided relationship
with them it's a two-sided what I was
noticed yeah and it's like no you
weren't no I mean like a guy messaged me
he was like oh I saw that you were
dating whoever well you know what it's
right I should let you go oh my god and
I'm just like yeah I never responded
once here and I have one of those yeah
yeah you just reminded me Oh like
everything that I do in the day right
like he'll be like oh my god you look so
beautiful today I love when you make
when you do your hair like that please
do it for me like that most hurt me like
like in a video like a youtube video
that I upload and like me and Bart kind
of seem like we're bickering he's like
he should never talk to you like oh like
a one-sided boyfriend or girlfriend f
initely you know cuz but streaming it's
these people are watching you for like
six hours a day maybe five days a week
and like I can't think of a single
person I hang out with and proud young
that long but for someone watching you
they're like oh yeah this is my best
friend but you don't really know they
exist and like it's a it's it's kind of
it's a really weird one-sided relation
there is a dude straight up on my chat
every time about to leave alright babe I
love you text me laughter okay and I'm
like oh my god what the [ __ ] his name
was half-time so okay I'm wondering if
you or Jeana if either of you guys
remember your first creepy streaming D
me like DM request and I'll tell you
mine first we'll try it oh yeah I feel
like everyone remembers their first one
it sounds really good it's just so weird
mine wasn't like this mine was like five
years ago
and it like this guy had just he had
sent me like a twitch message and like I
don't remember the twitch messaging yes
is Samantha see it was weird it was like
you you have an inbox or people like
just straight send you mess and you
could like send messages to subscribers
in like aa super throwback great great
platform anyways bye so somebody had
messaged me and they were like hello
Bo's I would like to offer you the
opportunity of a lifetime and like I
remember that line because I was like
well I would love that yeah yeah I'm
like go on and it's like I would like to
offer you any denomination of money that
you choose just for a small request
and so my stupid-ass response because
this is like a chance of a lifetime
chance of a lifetime me eleven water
like I'm like ready to go and I'm like
I'm like hey I'm interested like you
know interested to hear what you have to
say alright like I don't know how I
responded to it but you responded and in
a very long format message he asked me
for to make a request for how much money
I wanted and he wanted me to record a
video of me eating food that he chose
and then throwing it up oh [ __ ] and you
know at the time I was like really broke
but like it was so I was so I'm pretty
internet savvy at the time even though I
was very new to twitch and I was like
dude if I send this [ __ ] a video
of me throwing the money he paid up like
there's a video online of him being
probably like intestines and there's
like growing I yeah and so like oh I
remember now he wanted to pick the color
of the food oh that specifically what
you want and yeah that was that was my
first okay you get my way yes can I just
say whenever I hear about stuff like
this I really wonder where did this yes
a douche per se come from yeah okay
y'all are making me sweat
[Laughter]
sweat moving on to our next one I love
beautiful you guys are a goddamn anyhow
have you guys ever been to a convention
and smells like absolute ass because
nobody knows how to shower put on
deodorant yeah well lucky for you we
have this unit right here called native
which by the way poking just what
happens here you can you can model that
poky just so happens to be wearing it
right now Isis yeah I know that's how
you know I'm like hazing a real fan of
this podcast I buy the stuff you see
happening use the code BTC a discount no
free like this is on my face right now
I love the vanilla one I think that a
rose a12 recently I don't know if that's
all but this is a native deodorant they
have over eight thousand five star
reviews and I've been featured on TV and
in print and in pokies pits yeah very
true she smelled the room I can attest
to that there's a finish for that
somewhere right now there's fewer
simpler ingredients you know everything
that's in it aluminum you might have
heard may be linked to some serious
health ramifications so don't have
yeah which they don't have that was the
main reason I bought it mmm-hmm
and what she was saying earlier there's
a bunch of smells just coconut vanilla
which we have amazing huh yeah lavender
and Rose Byrne mints eucalyptus
everything just everything that you
might want look just and there's no risk
to try it free returns and exchanges all
the us isn't that amazing yeah so you
can use it and then lick it or whatever
the hell you want to do and then send it
back so if you subscribe you also save
$17 or just like $2 per stick oh yeah so
uh so far listeners oh sorry sir go
ahead pokey you want to tell our
listeners for 20% off your first
purchase visit native do to calm and use
promo code be T CH I think I'm doing a b
tch once again that's 20% off your first
purchase is visit
native deodorant calm and use a promo
code bt c age please forget mel the same
yeah welcome back to the episode creepy
gm's white knights and white knights
protective oh there's gonna be yeah
there's a little white you have a white
knight i didn't know what that was but
now I know yeah cool boom kaboom Black
Knight your room doesn't exist gray
night night it's just white Oh
have you ever had one white night you
whenever Bart says something like Bart
would be like that guy yeah you only as
wine know you're like at 9.5 you own
items one night you have to that's you
yeah it only right you sure there's more
yeah yeah meanwhile polka is like an
army of men white horse oh my god
they're gonna comment like how dare you
comment on her armpits China they're the
most beautiful armpits ever no ain't
sometimes I feel that banter with
someone like we're having a good time
like we're friends and something out
there's like I can't believe he's being
such an [ __ ] - I feel bad cuz I want
them to be like in on the joke yeah but
they're just not lights and I know their
intentions are good cuz like no like I
just don't want someone to insult you
was just a joke yeah don't worry about
it they think you're a lot more like
fragile and helpless than you really are
no you're thug you just made that hand
deodorant jackoff thing the earth ugh
that's a new tech by the way try it out
yeah we're revolutionize so you're very
good bra story for us earlier oh okay
it's a bro this is the first time that I
got a message and I was like damn some
people are all I did online and so I was
also very new to streaming maybe I had
student like four or five times and this
guy messaged me and I'm like
pardon me cuz I won't remember all the
details but you're part of that
something like yeah which one the
original I think the original came and I
didn't I didn't like remember everything
from the movie but apparently there's a
girl that eats something and turns into
violet you're turning violet
what you're talking about yeah she just
like sent me this long message no so
long ago so I just remember he mentioned
that and he was like I would really like
it if like you reenacted this like he
really turns me on I was like you want
me to like blows up into a blueberry or
something like I did not comprehend I
was like why
how are you attracted to this no and how
do we even accomplish this yeah
why are you so important that I have to
do it just for you yeah I mean I was he
paying you was he gonna pay you
I don't recall probably but I don't
recall but I'm thinking of just somebody
watching the Willy Wonka movie and
watching that scene and then being like
damn I wish that was pokey
right it's like literally like what
[ __ ] happened
I know that it's a [ __ ] popular
Finnish way maybe like just like you
know that Gucci purse I bought yes
you're the same guy or that was a sexual
awakening scene for many men yeah if it
was a sexual awakening scene for you
please let us know below in the comments
also what the [ __ ] imagine imagine
imagine like I know what it is because
it's like only see last week I was
running low there's actually no there's
actually like a hentai like anime porn a
fetish look I'm a creative Internet all
right [ __ ] you all and there's one there
like they like fill the girl up and like
try to like inflate her with semen love
with like whatever I think with like
semen or or like eggs like alien eggs I
mean The Hague insemination I think so
yeah it's very male fetish did you know
that I've heard of that yeah oh that's
pretty hot I close for that you getting
filled up with come make it talks about
all the time I'm not no being filled up
with alien alien eggs eggs like this oh
yeah yeah
dildos I insert it in you oh yeah
[Laughter]
once I hear there's some yeah okay um
have you guys heard okay
I'll start from the beginning okay yes
please sorry tank when I was a back in
Canada still streaming like part time I
had a peel box so every now and then
I'll do like peel box unboxings or
whatever and this one time I got a gem
from someone and I was like this pretty
like pink gem I was like oh cool and it
said like the like pink quartz or
something stands really attraction I
mean attracting affection into your life
and love and positive energy whatever
the heck and I was like all right and I
like put it up on my uh like my window
or something I just stood there and then
later like two three years later I was
watching this girl some morning routine
so random on YouTube and in her morning
routine she's just one of those what a
young yes yogi a Yoli yogi yogi egg
something like that they're like the
eggs put in your vagina is it for like
exercise or just yeah it was good and
you're like you're supposed to clench or
something and when I saw that I realized
that's what I was sent to my POS years
ago what the hell oh and I had like
moved up this is on my parents house I
left it on my your mom's like sign
Academy I was like I really hope my mom
never finds oh my god what I was
picturing like a diamond looking thing
no oh there it is though yeah
I got it I was like cool like I don't
know like a gym nice yeah really nice as
you get it was like oh my god that's so
wild
it's almost adorable it's like this
weird thing just hanging and there was
no note like no yeah right there chef in
a note no no do you often get like sex
toys to your p.o box actually no really
yeah um like very very random things I
get quite a bit of letters which is cute
I like the letters I got one thing once
also in Canada it was a stack of papers
I'm talking this this thick stack some
neighbors and most of them made no sense
I'm talking about characters everywhere
random colors yadda yadda and on one of
them the guy actually wrote and like I
feel kind of bad because he might have
been suffering from a mental illness I
don't know but it was it was insane he
was just saying things and relating me
to the most random stuff I remember he
took a picture of his backyard and there
was a cigarette pack in his backyard and
he was like my neighbors keep leaving
stuff like this on my lawn I know it's
connected to you like letters and I got
it on streem and I was like I wish I
could tell you guys but literally just
imagine like any scenario whatsoever and
then someone just like mental gymnastics
to relate it to yeah yeah I had somebody
I was listening to I was listening to a
song I was listening to a song by wax I
know he's been on JK a few times so just
throwing that out there it was like a
wack song and if anyone listens to him
like he's just he's just like a rapper
he's just like doing whatever and like
somebody took an excerpt from a song
that I was listening to on stream and
they sent it to me and they'd been like
if you miss me you could have just told
me and I deliberately went over and over
again to like like the lyric or
something about like it like hitting me
up all the time and then suddenly are
gone and I'm like brothers I was just
listening to a [ __ ] song I have a
boyfriend I didn't know about does that
too dude and I'm honest like there are
times for me where I'm like this is kind
of concerning like am I
okay because you know there are these
people online that don't um you know I
don't know it's like there's no boundary
for them like they if they want to be a
part of your life whether it'll good or
bad
like they will like they will be a part
of it you guys have never had like an
actual like stalker like somebody I did
that's where my name came from I changed
my last name because I had a stalker he
was like I know where you live I'm gonna
come cut your brakes and he sent me
flowers yeah so I had to change I got a
restraining order and then I had to
change all my social media names and I
can think of what name to put and then I
just heard the word darling on TV I was
like I always put that for now
unfortunately like you good business I
love intentionally I need it I mean like
actually because it's like too cute yeah
like it doesn't fit me adds a layer to
like Oh Gina darling they fry your wild
damn it no literally came in with like
gun holstered it was hot but yeah after
that I just change the name and then I
got stuck with that name because that's
when everything started taking off and
now I'm just stuck with a stripper name
now suits you Thanks it's so cute it's
super super the craziest thing I ever
had happen and I know I'm not even on
your guys's radar in terms of like crazy
it's just someone pants it does but I
feel like you guys deal with a lot more
I just don't get it though because like
Gio you're like no you know what it is
you know what it is it's because like
the more like like you're like sweet
right and you're very kind and you're
alright because they can you know
dominate yeah you're a big [ __ ] yeah
yeah I I got less crazy [ __ ] yeah I
started being meaner yeah you cuz you
yeah yeah when you're like soft and nice
and like they want to save you that's
all the creepy [ __ ] starts coming in
saving everyone picture so you like
Queen
a little anime queen no but the craziest
thing was just someone showed up to my
house when we weren't there and they
left the post to no huge fan
yeah houses you wanna say before this no
when we thought started before when we
first started on work um yeah so they
just left the post-it note I'm like
we're the biggest fans like it's so like
nice I would love to come by again and
know and see what's up but I was like
what the [ __ ] this is so weird but
that's like the extent that's said dude
you said you had one you said people
showed up to your house people actually
don't tell them how sorry no I just I
live with a bunch of friends
soren like this gamer frat house
basically we're in there seven I
subtract six or seven do you ever
is there like ever any quiet time cuz I
can't imagine um likes to bed I'll say
that much but it's not bad because we
all have enough like room or space to
live our own lives if that makes doesn't
feel crowded but yeah there's always
usually something there's a fatass house
okay got it
it wasn't always upgrade okay I think I
was I just remembered I think I've been
to your house before when I was really
drunk probably old house maybe somebody
invited me over and I went to like I
left the bathroom to go back into his
room and I opened the wrong person store
and you saw the dyke gym for the vagina
this dude and he was streaming and I was
drunk and I just looked at him and I was
like I [ __ ] I think it was SCARA and
I like ya know we have like such a gamer
frat house that like we will have
parties and still like two of us will be
streaming throughout the whole party but
yeah between like the seven of us our
address gets leaked at some point oh
yeah but speaking of addresses you know
we can come straight to your address
legally our next sponsor oh oh who is
this
that was so [ __ ] [ __ ] leave and I
love there's so much more for that yes
I'm so proud oh my god I love her to
introduce our next sponsor door - cuz
yes they can deliver your favorite
restaurant meal favorite right to your
doorstep yeah like what it time to be is
an essential thing for gamers by the way
essential essential we're eager wait
hold on no we're not good yeah
so craving anything in particular I'm
craving multiple things definitely you
just go online you download their app
door - and they have tons and tons of
restaurants from like seafood - pasta -
pizza - Donuts - I've ordered batteries
off a door - more cuz I'm balling like
that yes it connects you to your
favorite restaurants is my point
ordering is easy they have over they
have about 310 amazing ugly 310,000 my
bad amazing restaurants and it's local
to goes or choose from your favorite
chains like Chipotle Cheesecake Factory
and you don't have to worry about dinner
so for all of our listeners right now
you guys are gonna get five dollars off
your first order of $15 or more it was
easy flows more easy actually
yeah so that's five dollars your first
order when you when you download the
door - app from the App Store and enter
promo code hey girl hey girls yeah so
it's gonna be hate okay okay so again
that's promo code hey girl
with five dollars off your first order
from door - that was really good you I'm
I do it I'm gonna slap my face just to
my friend back down that was a good hi
she was incorporated like she like threw
the alley-oop and I like was about to
miss it so you
I was like Oh ships Duncan I love I love
the kind of the the White Nights and
then you know the angle of just I don't
raise II people we haven't spoke about
the people showed up oh yeah
so Oh our dress gets leaked sometimes
I'll tell you guys non recent ones cuz I
don't like to give attention others
right right there was a guy at our last
house or two houses ago our last house
hmm
and he would send me random messages and
sometimes I would see them like either a
random Twitter DM
I mean Twitter mention or sometimes if I
look at my outbox on Instagram but I
usually don't so I miss the majority of
them until the incident escalated so
basically I remember at one point I saw
him message something like I'm arriving
at LAX in oh yeah tomorrow afternoon
hope to see you there or something and
obviously if this is the first message
you read only see from someone you're
like I read a message whatever you like
I like he didn't recognize his username
didn't know he was so I was like oh just
a troll whatever however he said
something like maybe we can meet at the
public library no I get the information
this guy's here to book the private
library no I feel bad because like
sometimes you you can't tell like
whether these people have ill intent
whether like they just feel really
connected to you or if they have some
kind of a mental illness and it could be
any of the above so I don't want to
speak as if like I'm talking down on him
or anything there's just an incident
that I'm talking about and it has a
pretty good ending I think so he was
arrested he had a library card library
really cute okay right so I was showing
one day streaming and this is when we
had different roommates than we
currently do and one of them had a dog
and he was walking his dog in your house
and he messages me and he goes I met
this random guy on the street who's
looking for you and I was like
and he like he like snuck a picture
behind his shoulder of the dude and
basically this guy was just like he knew
our general area oh my god know which
house we lived at so he was just like
walking around and he saw my roommate
and he was like are you blah blah blah
and he's like yeah and he's like I need
you to take me to pokey Maine like oh I
must meet her like were meant to be my
queen as I was and obviously that's kind
of freaky for me and then he kind of
lost the dude or he was like yeah like I
gotta go I'm not going home made sure he
like wasn't oh good smart on him yeah I
came back I was freaked out I was like
door closed locked streaming so if I die
y'all are at least amp up to 24 hours
dream guys I think about that like if
someone ever break up I break into my
house and kids better [ __ ] like call
the call word every yeah oh the cop
somebody has my address oh yeah I'm live
leak yeah right that way absolutely and
yeah I'm trying to member exactly what
happened but basically uh I learned of
his existence per se when he interacted
with my roommate and then I went and
looked into like his DMS and his
mentions further because I had only seen
like that Twitter that that tweet and I
was like wow whatever just like meeting
me at LAX like that's so random I went
into his Instagram diems dude minds of
just like responding to my stuff and
sometimes it was like oh like you look
really nice here and sometimes it's like
like something about commies like the
spectrum insane it was like I'm really
really nice or like let me like describe
in extreme detail what I would like you
to do to me or what I would like to do -
I was like oh maybe IQ just wants to
meet me but when I saw that nasty stuff
I was like uh-uh screenshots I wish I
like knew I would a prep dish of it
No - my favorite part is that the first
thing that caught your mind was that he
says yes why he wanted you to do to him
that everything no like they just the
most random detail like and I can tell
just like some random evening and he
just like just sends me this paragraph
message at night or something and I was
like thank God I didn't read these
before because this is creepy as heck oh
and I remember I know that it's all
coming back yeah yeah great that's great
I have so many of these stories just
buried I remember when I would play with
other guys on stream like just friends
he would like message them and be like
you better back off
I'd love that though when I was like
eight joke if it was like my boyfriend
but in summer and um dude and I like
scrolling through his stuff I was like
I've never responded to anything you
said yeah you know that that was the
most insane thing to me and then he flew
down here right that was the most insane
thing not him flying to you no no I mean
um that aspect of like maybe it's like
we interacted like yeah mine he could
have thought like I would have wanted
more it's like I never wanted to stop
yeah and it's like a level further um
once I like further research into it and
my roommate spoke to me about it more he
basically said I think this guy might
have had like a family and he like crazy
he said that he was staying at a public
park what yeah places say he was just
like staying in a public park and I was
like how do you charge your phone to
like tweeting yeah we're gonna let him
charge it I didn't even know if it was
serious but yeah basically
that's what he said he said something
about having a family and staying in a
public park and like lying down here
maybe he was from like North Cal or
somebody seemed older um probably late
20s oh yeah and basically then he went
into this other female streamers
community like her discord or something
broke up with you not quite he went in
to talk about me but then everybody in
her community was like no dude like you
need help like
this is Nokia below blah and last we
heard he'd like did get help oh yeah
that's why I say it gives a pretty good
day I was hoping there were gonna be too
many bubbles because I was I was
invested but I wanted everyone okay
that's insane yeah yeah like you know I
think I think I make a common thing for
streamers because I've I know this is
like a really common thing for people to
donate and be like well I'm going
through this and I'm going through this
and you know creators as a whole we're
like saying like hey we care about you
and we want you to get help but I am NOT
I can't [ __ ] them up more yeah like you
know if I'm here for you to kind of have
an escape like get some help on the side
and like let's you know you'll figure it
all out but like we cannot directly
coach each and every person that's going
through so I think I think one of my pet
peeves when I'm streaming is you know
that you have I'm sure you have those
guys I try to get attention with
negative stories guys my dog died today
and I'm in the hospital
you know hey I know you guys been
wondering where I am I haven't like like
he'll just tell everyone like yeah you
know I've been in surgery oh but no
surgery tomorrow guys wish me luck I'm
just saying oh what a point come on like
oh you don't like them we don't like
that look off guy because like if you
want attention what you want positive
attention you know like attention 110
there's so many things that that tick me
off when it comes I say that is because
like when you really think about it the
reason these people are acting out in
ways that annoy us even like trying to
like gather around a pity party or get
you to feel bad for them it's probably
because they don't have anyone in their
lives that yeah yes bad but this one in
particular because I only had one would
go to every girl and do that and then
eventually ask for pictures it's like oh
that was like except Edie yeah but it's
like oh yeah yeah I'm so lonely hey but
do you want to see a picture of my dick
or like do you have any photos where's
the link right like this yeah I I think
my biggest pet peeve for like streaming
and like just
people commenting and stuff it's like
when they say something nice they say
something nice and you don't catch the
first two and then they're like well
[ __ ] you you know they'll be like
they'll be like god you're really having
an off day today aren't you
what do you only have one eyelash but so
you know in order it's always mid
teamfight to like flakes often like
they're like oppressed left to [ __ ]
shoot like left quick yeah and I'm like
dude so what I try to do is like when
people say positive stuff I try to
encourage that and pay attention to that
and if you see some mean [ __ ] to me I'm
gonna ignore you and it's and at this
point it's second nature because like I
don't want to endorse you saying mean
things to other people to get attention
I want you to see nice things to them so
I tried it uplift the most I mean like
sounds so wack but I try to up like have
the most positive behavior because you
know the way that people you know act in
my channel and what I allow it bleeds
over into other people's work too I
really believe that I wish more
streamers realize that especially bigger
ones yeah like what's the T what do you
go drop some names there was a lot of
controversy the last like maybe couple
months or something where people were
basically debating about whether or not
a streamer should be responsible for
their community and it's like yeah I
think right like if one random dude that
watches you goes and does some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like oh yeah that's not your fault
yeah but if you let people run rampant
and then that leads into other people's
communities can you really be surprised
especially if like you do nothing to try
to tell people what the boundaries are
within this platform or how you should
treat other broadcasters yeah yeah I
think I think it's exactly if it's a
sorry yeah I thought the reason that's
kind of annoying is because it's pretty
easy to realize that the more you don't
give a [ __ ]
the more viewers will probably be in
your stream and once you start like
filtering being like no like let's be
this way maybe your community will be a
little smaller and sometimes people like
just don't want to take that viewer hit
though they'd rather just like as much
attention as much your ship regardless
of whether what I'm doing is good or bad
you know what I mean yeah and you know
what it's fine they just want to do that
it plays a lot into numbers
cuz they don't want to lose that chunk
and maybe know 10 or 20% but and I'm and
just say this [ __ ] like go off your few
people that hasn't had to deal with the
life cycle of a streamer like I don't
think some people really understand that
you are not going to be ads like super
[ __ ] big forever like there is a
timeline you know there are some people
that are in like maybe the upper echelon
the top 10% that their career they when
they hit a peak they jump to the next
ledge but some people sit on this peak
and they're like okay this is it
like I'm 15,000 viewers for life and
like you're not you you have to either
jump to the next ledge or mold your
community into something positive that's
gonna have a trajectory but if you're
just riding the high of popularity or
you know you're a streamer where you
know being rude and like you know having
mob mentality and you know attacking
other people is your brand that anyone's
gonna copy you're gonna turn on you yeah
they're gonna turn they're gonna copy
your brand they're gonna go somewhere
else' City is not a brand it's really
not yes Gina you mean like I have a mob
oh you do I know what the [ __ ] we're
like vigilante justice mob as you keep
him yeah no really they're really chill
about it like it's it's more one of
those like we need to protect Gina mob
when I love them yeah yeah you know what
I think that I your mob should go to
sleep with Buffy oh [ __ ] this is so much
better so much better let's cover you
know what Gina let's put the haters too
bad
guys I am so excited they we all it
apart we are forever a Buffy sponsorship
because this is not just a sponsorship
this is my life I almost lost my job the
other day guys because I was knocked out
cold on god this computer well walk you
have a storm then Ronda Rousey on her
period I swear to god hey you'll be out
so fast like a light you all know when
you get in those hotel beds I haven't
even read the paper yet this is just all
me boys look ya'll know when you get in
the hotel bed and you're like wow this
is
prising Lee comfy I can't believe this
it's not the mattress it is the
comforter I'm not kidding it is I only
interact not the mattress it really is
let me tell y'all Buffy maybe Betty that
is earth friendly and cruelty-free it is
a hundred percent eucalyptus fiber to
keep you cool through the night I know
y'all you like your fan on you like to
be all cold but protected don't stick a
toe out the monsters will get you yeah
that's true the breeze regulates
temperature no more night sweat get cozy
without overheating and why not choose a
hundred percent plant-based bedding
that's better for you and the earth I
mean I really i but like seriously like
earth aside like y'all yeah say there
are the side how about me how about me
and my comfort it's like like I love
going to sleep in the blanket and I also
love waking up in the morning with it I
I'm serious like and then the other
thing that it is when you put this
blanket on your bed when you walk into
your bedroom and you look at it you're
like that's my cloud that's my [ __ ]
cloud and I'm about to lay in it and I'm
gonna have a blast and you and your own
Buffy I need you to know I think I need
to buy another one I won't waters off by
just going to Buffy CEO and entering the
code b tch and tell him to bow Sencha
that's a that's a come again though
that's $20 off your first comfort or
visit Buffy dot C oh okay and then enter
code b tch and guys you get to try this
comforter for free or I think it's 60
days you're not gonna be sleeping
exactly but if you do want to return it
you can return it for free but yeah
that's what I thought it won't gonna say
that you won't do it thinking about her
right now
[Laughter]
yeah I'm this is this is wild you guys
yeah well you know this is what I'm okay
I'm gonna be honest I'm a little bit
jealous I wish I had that type of
commitment for my for my followers you
know I bought you know what I bet geo
secretly has like some ace family [ __ ]
you have like some like 12 year old kids
a bit bit
wish they'd Barton you were their
parents yeah we did wait up there you're
right we do have I [ __ ] absolutely
right all the time yeah it's it's that
way but I want that crazy love you you
want that yeah you do have that you want
it till you got it trust me you know I'm
just kidding I don't want it speed of
love I want to know is there another or
is there another sponsor oh I want to
know and I'm sure a lot of people want
to know what kind of guys are you into
because it's like you're like the
pinnacle of like I want to wipe the [ __ ]
out of it well not the ones that are
deeming that weird [ __ ] so yeah I
learned from that don't do that yeah
yeah you are like wifey status like you
have a look but then you're also like
driven business woman's successful
entertainment Empire and I'm like oh wow
I just want to stay at home and not work
and I want this to be my wife like
personal oh yeah you guys heard it first
here everybody she's single all right
let's go
physical first all right let's talk
about how he should look like what woody
what do you like to be honest it's it's
really hard for me to say because I've
had crushes on all sorts of dudes post
like literally whole spectrum I've had
crushes on dudes shorter than me I
thought cursed on dudes I'm like 6 4
I've liked every shade of color every
other guy with one leg thing I wanna see
if the personality was a big ok y'all
looking at the best thing confidence yes
I solutely because I'm 23 now going
through some [ __ ] but I realize I can't
be fixing nobody yeah you need to be
fixing you I need to be fixing we can
help each other out 20 and you're saying
this [ __ ] I'm 36 I'm like barely figure
I got a fixture in the back waiting for
me right now
you have to like learn a lot of [ __ ] at
once yeah I just mean like I've dealt
with guys that have insecurities and
I've realized like I want to help so
much mm-hmm and it just barely ever
makes a difference yeah um so I think
I'm kind of a little bit over that so
I think confidence I'm really into dudes
that are ambitious but that's the worst
[ __ ] cuz I'm they're so damn busy they
can't pay yeah I get it yeah
ambitious confident I mean I've I
realized like I need a dude who's smart
enough like you have to be
intellectually stimulating and I feel
like the attraction always comes after
that oh my god I I was like seeing this
dude for a while and I always thought my
whole life that it's like you know
people on like a shallow level but if
you talked to them enough like you'll
get to know them on a deeper level I've
dated that like just I kept looking yeah
I was like dig no he's just a nice kind
of fun it's like oh he's mysterious yeah
and then it's like there's nothing for
breakfast every morning and just toast
that's all I know man I don't know I
don't know how to explain it until
you've like encountered yeah I don't
know okay thank God but it is kind of
like that where you're thinking like no
there's got to be more there's that yeah
and maybe he's been secure he's
intimidated or he's like you know and
you like try to put him in different
scenarios or asking questions yes like
hmm okay well maybe I'm not doing it
right and if you don't ask like a really
deep hypothetical question you're just
like haha I don't know you guys know
those memes of like like the hot
douchebags in high school like the way
they text mm-hmm I don't know it's
literally haha I don't know crazy
yeah yeah dude I said the guy is it like
they were hot all through high school so
they didn't have to develop personality
yeah yeah so [ __ ] ugly like I had to
I had to work very hard this is survival
for us yeah I agree with you on that
yeah like I like I will develop if you
ever say you know those girls at like
nowadays the 14 year olds that had like
perfect makeup and they look great and
that like they never went through the
ugly eyebrow phase like you have to go
through they have the eyebrows yeah
caterpillars yeah ugly stages build
great character yeah yeah Brian coming
up it's like if you're hot like people
just instantly like you like in high
school we had nothing to go off of so we
were like oh you're closer great you're
attractive you must be cool but like for
the rest of us we kind of had to like
develop money yeah like we had been
funding something to survive in middle
school I was also not I were like the
same so every day good girl but always
were the same sweater and never wash
your pants dirty I use them I bet I bet
my point being like during that phase I
always use on the internet all the time
and I feel like when you're on the
internet when you're young like you're
just forced to kind of grow up like 12
13 but I'm like no I'm actually 16 I'm
like pretty full and all these people
catfishing people I can't fish my first
person at eleven brightspace is like oh
my god I say his AOL screen name so
somebody can find him I can't say in
everybody right you know I think he was
like 16 but I was like yeah I'm 16 too
chat rooms good lord do it this happens
in your child in the internet and just
like what that is like I at one time on
the internet someone called me Gina is a
creature of the Internet and I was proud
of that
yeah that's cuz I yeah that's how I grew
up too like I was on the internet all
the time from like middle school til now
and I'm just a full-on degenerate now
that's great I love it same here yeah
you were asking her about like her
dating right oh yeah yeah yeah okay so
have you ever encountered like um when I
meet people right then I'm like somewhat
interested in one of the few things like
one of the first things I ask is what is
your Instagram so I can look up and see
if they're following my co-stars to see
if they're a fan because I will not date
a fail yeah I will not date a fan have
you ever encountered like anything kind
of similar to that like maybe like I
don't want a date a fan it's kind of
weird for me it's not like just a fan
it's like any time someone any time I
feel someone's treating me differently
solely because of my following it's just
like this can't be released yeah I can
it's just impossible um oh my god I
remember I went to a party recently I'm
so sorry I was 1 out this week I'm so
tame all year round I'm gonna go to
parties I can I was like I'm never going
out of her again no connect like the
night went fine and then at the end it
was like oh like let's connect boba and
this guy asked for my Instagram and then
as soon as he saw my follower account
his eyes went huh and it was like it
went from yeah I'm gonna get my uber and
go home to like hey like let me show you
my go back to your place like I thought
it's nice but it was like I could tell
but it was not nice was object or not
he's not going to oh okay he's pretty
cute
okay I love a strong six I just like I I
would never want to like see this and I
thought it was pretty chill but then I
just thought like Ana started treating
me differently once yeah that I was like
it it doesn't make you very inclined to
talk to them at the end of day like in
relationship you want it to be two equal
people and once one of them is already a
fan prior to entering the relay yeah it
just creates a weird dynamic yeah yeah
yeah I like a trophy all the time
yeah strange and like they might treat
you a certain way like you maybe in a
sense taking advantage of them even if
you don't even if you aren't trying to
yeah you just know though like you can
walk all over there was a there was a
guy that got mad at me because he's like
oh um this is like in the beginning of
kind of seeing each other and then he
kind of got to know more of what I do
and he got mad at me because I wouldn't
come meet his friends last minute and it
was like a couple times I'm like dude
like I'm busy I'm working yeah he's like
and then afterwards he's like my friends
don't believe that I'm dating you like
what am I supposed to I'm like oh oh you
want me to meet them to prove it yeah
you already just show up and make you
look good he's like well I mean I feel
like you don't you're not proud of being
with me because I asked you to meet my
friends and like they just think that
I'm making things up now I'm like all
right this is getting kind of [ __ ]
weird like I'm starting it like that
trophy feeling I don't like it yeah it's
so I like and also the guy that I'm
dating like we literally he's a student
and we met on tinder okay him yeah yeah
super like super laid back guy like he
doesn't like run around like flashing my
following or anything everywhere and I
mean like he's cool in the sense that
he's like hey you should really you
should keep doing this this is part of
your business like that's so cool yeah
he endorses me like working on that side
of things but like doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah you know yeah and I just I love
like I feel like for dating for me like
being with somebody that you feel like
you're walking the same path with is
very very very important you know like
they support you and you support them
and it's like an equivalent exchange
yeah that's and that's that's what it's
all about like that is the fulfillment
that you get from love and like treating
each other like a trophy
or like you know some of these guys
there are guys with low self-esteem that
are like oh if I date this girl that has
this big following I'll feel good about
myself
yeah don't work like that like yeah I
can accomplishment rather than a partner
yeah good feeling yeah and that turns
into like like damn it like she's doing
better than me oh my god I'm like like
like then they start kind of holding you
back or it turns into you know
unbeknownst to them and I really say
this like honestly I don't think some
people realize that they they really
they think that dating you will validate
them it's like they're like okay
dating this person will make me feel
better and then as the relationship goes
on and they don't feel better they're
like why didn't you they're mentally
thinking like why didn't you make me
feel better like do I yeah it's kind of
your fault and it's just like it's just
overall messy situation yeah you know
yeah I gotta say like hmm that doesn't
mean like I'll never date someone that
like knows who I am but it's all in like
how you interact yeah yes you know what
I mean hundred percent yeah like I
showed a guy my following he think I'm
like all right cool drop them drop I
like seeing difference thank you do you
guys know scooter yeah yeah he
discovered or he man it's just Justin
Bieber yeah my boy he discovered or I
guess like he first saw his I think now
wife because she did a TED talk and he
watched it and really liked what she
said he's like I need to meet her like
that's like Oh at least like they're
valuing you because they like something
yeah and it's like I want to meet them
and get to know them as opposed like
they have this many followers so I want
to be with them yeah because they have
this many followers
yeah they depends where someone's coming
from yeah and you know also to fall in
love with somebody's like following or
their online persona is not really yeah
yeah but you know a TED talk she's
talking about her knowledge and what she
knows and it shows that she's like a
smart strong well-spoken woman dude like
you were saying confidence somebody on
stage doing a TED talk right that's
right yeah sexy I dated a guy a couple
weeks and then within a couple weeks is
a hate are you gonna post me on your
Instagram are you gonna tag me and like
you mean yeah I'm like all right get the
[ __ ] out of here what did you really say
no I said I was like no because I don't
post early now you got mad about it I'm
like hey do you want the password
[ __ ] social media
ah I'm like this is my business you want
to [ __ ] run my business and only two
weeks yeah
dude all right you guys show me his face
later yeah if I can find him oh god is
he cute
at least for me that's such a hard
question to answer
after like I have an occurrence with
someone because like the way I see
someone yeah it mostly depends on like
how we interact yeah yeah yeah you find
yourself more attracted to people that
are in your field like the creative
field or more like the personality a
nine-to-five field or a little bit of
both I feel like I don't get to meet
enough people that are just 9 to 5 right
no I think I could be fine with either
hey just like all I need is someone
who's like open-minded yeah is willing
to support me and I'm happy to support
them intellectually stimulating and we
get along yeah yeah yeah it's like so
easy why so hard it's like on paper it
sounds so you see like don't be a dick
and don't be [ __ ] crazy and don't use
me we need to get sponsored by a dating
app all right Oh Mike do you got oh you
show me all the mics it's things okay at
one point I was like I need love no just
kidding I was like oh like why not try
dating apps because to some extent it
can help you filter through the things
that like no I'm like yeah exactly
um and I've always liked liked kind of
meeting people online I'll be enough
like yeah I've just like gotten used to
it asked out who's online a lot the fun
without yeah yeah for me to meet
somebody online than it would be today
is how I grew up yeah
and so like anyways so I couple apps I
think not tinder but I think like hinge
and Safi meets bagel go find her
go find her right now there was an
online maybe I Cupid something I don't
know I tried like two or three within 24
hours on every single one band like no
class what happened to me well yeah well
this is this so I was like okay maybe
they think I'm catfishing me yeah all
right so I signed up to on
their dating app and I was like I'm
gonna link my Instagram so I can be like
this is me hmm I do that this time it
took 48 hours still bad like that's they
don't even go like can you prove that
this is you and it's like I linked my
literal Instagram Oh weird oh my god and
someone I like her like it just start
sparking you guys know what shipping is
yeah oh yes yeah I've been shipped with
a lot of guys yeah a time being my
roommate
his name is fed and like I go by pokey
so our ship name is like foki that's
cute someone like I guess someone like I
accepted them and they accepted me and
they messaged me and they go fed would
be disappointed oh my me and David like
whenever I post the picture of the guy
like how does how would David feel but
brother also imagine that guy matching
with pokey and just [ __ ] it to you
you stupid [ __ ] two options
hey or fed would be just ya or [ __ ] it
up basically what I can leave a door
[ __ ] like block cock-block myself
so we cap you're an idiot okay it's just
so weird reading stuff like that when
people are like you are dating this
person I know you are and it's like I'm
not like I wish I was dating someone
I'm just not yeah absolutely there was a
there was one time I tried like the
dating apps a couple years ago for like
for funsies to see what happens and this
guy was talking me like he didn't know
who I was but me being me oh no I found
him on Instagram cuz like it's [ __ ]
easy yeah he was following all of us and
then I stopped responding and then he
messaged me on Instagram and said oh wow
I didn't know I was talking to someone
so famous I'm like [ __ ] you yeah I know
exactly what you were doing it was so
disgusting I feel bad for you guys
yeah so what have we learned today we
learned that bookie single she tells
like vanilla yeah she has no idea what a
Keagle egg does but it's real pretty
yeah
put on the show how nice yeah start
sending her random things that look kind
of pretty
yeah and just watch her stream receive
it's in the background thanks again to
our sponsors native door - and Buffy for
20% off of your first purchase of native
deodorant visit native deodorant calm
and use the promo code b-tch at checkout
also right now our listeners can get
five dollars off their first order of
$15 or more when you when you download
the door - app and into the promo code
hey girl
H ey GI RL and for $20 off of your
buzzer visit Buffy CO and into the code
b TCH and don't forget guys give us five
stars on iTunes I think we just hit 3.2
like three thousand two hundred five
star reviews insane crazy yeah yeah
that's pretty cute you're so nice we
just no lawyer is so pleasant I want you
to just read me a book at night I do it
like a mother Goose book oh my next
career stuff I'm just like inaudible yes
oh yeah like on stream i do like
late-night streams like alright gather
round kids reachable that would be so
yeah I would love that
there you go yeah yeah I actually did
like when I read a really touching
passage like I'll read it on stream guys
I thought this was really meaningful
maybe some of you it will resonate I can
see where you get the crazy that I would
feel like I'm in a relationship
yeah things where can you go find you um
P okay ima and
E on Twitch and I think Facebook and
then just throw in a little lol
afterwards for Instagram Twitter yeah
Google it check you know industry you
stream every day or five days a week not
every day like around for I would say
solid four times four days a week but on
YouTube yeah if this is me damn no more
like me but you're everyone yeah my guy
friends are in lovely someone took a
couple strands in here yeah
thanks Amy how many guys this is your
first time watching content with pogey I
hope you love her as much as we do like
baby this is awesome I think I hope you
guys enjoy yeah like I really enjoy this
podcast I hope I made it at least now
you killed it yeah you were amazing
oh yes all the tea all the tea alright
guys make sure you follow us on
instagram twitter it's hey [ __ ] podcast
we'll put our socials in the video as
well we'll see this next time bye
[ __ ]